foreign
of stopping him hunting and shooting
your first memory after being born
anything as a child I mean it was a very
unhappy childhood I remember seeing my
father slap my mother across the face I
was hiding behind the door and she was
crying
oh
[Music]
the Press were being unbearable
following my every move is it any
possibility if any announcements was
just your marriage and your future can
you tell me
he sat me down he said will you marry me
I thought the whole thing was hysterical
getting married it was so grown up and
he was Diana kindergarten teacher I mean
the whole thing was ridiculous
I once heard him on the telephone saying
whatever happens I'll Always Love You
and I told him I'd listen to the door we
had a filthy wow
and I realized I'd take it on the
enormous row but I had no idea that I
was going into
[Applause]
no idea
[Music]
I remember him coming to all four to
stay
[Music]
the Chinese Labrador
my sister was all over him like a bad
rash
[Music]
oh God he must really hate that
and I kept out of the way
I remember being fat podgy non-maker and
smart lady but I made a lot of noise and
you like that
and he just came out to me after dinner
we had a big dance and he said will you
show me the gallery
for a 16 year old for someone like that
to show any attention was just so
sort of amazed
why would anyone let him be interested
in me
anyway that was it for about two years
so I'm off along with Sarah
so I've got a excited about the whole
thing
[Music]
then she saw something different
happening
which I hadn't twigged onto
when he had his 30th birthday dance I
was asked to
well why is Diana coming as well
I said well I don't know but I'd like to
come
oh all right
and had a very nice time dance
fascinating
[Music]
and then
um I was asked to stay with the
departures in July by Philip to pass
if you like to come because we've got
principal staying and your young blood
you're mighty music
so I said okay
the first night we sat down on the veil
and I said you know you look so sad
when you walked up the ah there's some
pools
with long mcbutton's funeral
and I said my heartbread for I watched
it I thought was wrong or lonely
it used to be with somebody look after
Etc
and the next minute he left on me
practically
and it was very strange because it was
almost as if
like it wasn't a magnet effect
I thought well this isn't very cool I
thought men were supposed to not be so
obvious
but I had gotten to go by because I
never had a boyfriend I'd always kept
them away
I thought they were all trouble and I
couldn't handle it
emotionally I was so screwed up I
thought
and he said oh you must come to London
with me tomorrow I got to go and work at
Buckingham Palace I thought this is too
much I said no I can't I'm sorry
I thought how would I explain my
presence Buckingham Palace where I'm
supposed to be staying with Philip
and then it sort of built up from there
Charles used to ring me up and say would
you like to come for a walk would you
like to come for barbecues so I said yes
please
I thought this was all wonderful
Lady Diana was back at the Pimlico
kindergarten where she teaches this
morning but polite as ever she was
saying nothing about her weekend with
Prince Charles at Sandringham to the
assembled press Corps she drove off in
her brand new Mini Metro with a smile I
managed to have a word with her later
outside her Kensington flat
possibilities if any announcements of
your marriage and your future can you
tell me
[Music]
can you tell me if there's any
possibility
I'm not gonna say anything babe but
Prince Charles did give us a hint
himself he said we wouldn't have to wait
too long
he said we wouldn't have to wait too
long
we'll see sorry I decided your theme
when he said we wouldn't have to wait
too long
Prince Charles of Britain is perhaps the
world's most eligible bachelor early 30s
handsome rich and the heir to the
British throne London was full of rumors
this week that he may now be about to
take a bride the photographers are
trailing Lady Diana Spencer 19 years old
daughter of the eighth Earl of Spencer
she fits the qualifications aristocratic
good looking and well healed
[Music]
she is said to be besotted by him and
that in the queen's English means I
presume that she's in love
sweet kind nice and shy are all the
terms used to describe her a girl born
to be Queen
ideal for the most eligible bachelor in
the western world
even the queen were told thinks she's
delightful and that is as good as saying
that mother approves her pedigree is
perfect her father is the Aether Spencer
a wealthy landowner who Farms fifteen
thousand acres in the heart of the
northamptonshire countryside
children's parties do you remember any
of that yeah I hate you down
I've always hated parties that's why I
don't have on my own Daddy loves parties
right and organize it and took great
pride in that but there were still none
of the arms around the shoulder or the
hugging yeah there's always the other
things yeah which is probably what he
had too
I mean it was a very unhappy childhood
parents are busy sorting themselves out
obviously my mother crying
daddy never spoke to us about it we
could ever ask questions
too many changeover of nannies
very unstable
the whole thing
I just remember being generally unhappy
I'm being very detached from everybody
else
how did you first learn about the
divorce
I remember seeing my father slap my
mother across the face and I was hiding
behind the door and she was crying
and I remember mommy cried an awful lot
every Saturday when we went up weekends
every Saturday night we put a standard
procedure she'd start crying on Saturday
we both see a crime what's the matter
mommy oh I don't want you to leave
tomorrow which four uh nine year old was
devastating
no
as a child any ideas of futures or
ambitions
always felt very different from everyone
else very attached
he was going somewhere different
I have no idea where
and said to my father when I was the age
of 13 on the public eye I don't know
which way yes thinking that our
ambassador's wife actually what
one
since leaving school she's lived in a
100 000 pound flat in South Kensington
given to her by her father
it was nice being a fat with girls and I
love that it's great laugh my head off
there
my three girls were wonderful
star performers loyalty beyond belief
I kept myself to myself I wasn't
interested in having a full Diary
how will you coping with all the
presentation well as you can you can see
you can tell are you bearing up with it
quite well though because it must be
quite a strain with all of us
well it is naturally
any chases involved in the media in the
car and lots of them
but I always made sure that I went
through just as the light was going to
red
so they were very stuck
sometimes I cycle some days I didn't
really chased me everywhere
we're talking about 30 off and we're not
talking back to
um
[Music]
Lady Diana
yesterday that it may be coming soon
have you any comment to make about that
okay
have a good weekend though
[Music]
Charles ran me up and chose to say I've
got something to ask you
Instinct in a female you know what's
coming
anyway I sat up all night at my girls
saying what do I do what do I say
by that time I had realized there was
somebody else around
[Music]
I've been staying a bow hide with the
park bows it's an awful lot
I couldn't understand why Camilla kept
saying to me do this don't do that
she knew so much about what he was doing
privately
[Music]
eventually I worked all out
the next day I went to Windsor I arrived
about to five o'clock
he sat me down he said will you marry me
and I laughed
I remember thinking this is a joke let's
ask you okay
and he was deadly serious he says we do
realize just one day you'll be Queen
a voice said to me inside
you won't be Queen but you'll have a
toughra
so I thought to myself okay
so I suggest
and I said I love you so much I love you
so much
he said whatever love means
said it then
so I thought that was great I hope we
meant that
yeah
or not actually
in my immaturity which was enormous
I thought that he was very much in love
with me which he knows if so I had the
besotted look about him looking back at
it but it wasn't the genuine sort you
know who is this going so different but
he couldn't understand it because he's
immature which is quite good in that
part
and um I'm like Call for Duty really
go and work with people
before I knew what happened I was in
Clarence House
nobody there to welcome me
like going to a hotel and then everyone
said why clout house and I said because
I was told that I was expected to be
experience house
so I left my fat for the last time and
suddenly I had a policeman and my police
were the Night board engagement had said
to me
I just want you to know that this is
your last night of Freedom ever in the
rest of your life
to make the most of it
and it's like a sword went in my heart
I thought God
Charles Phillip Arthur George Windsor
heir to the British throne Prince of
Wales Earl of Chester Duke of Cornwall
and great Steward of Scotland has
finally chosen his bride she is Lady
Diana Spencer and their engagement is
the news Britain has been waiting for
foreign
Prince Charles and Lady Diana appeared
for the first time in public
[Music]
do you find it a daunting experience
that yesterday you were a nanny looking
after children
now you're about to marry the Prince of
Wales and and one day you would all they
know likely would be Queen
a tremendous change for someone for most
say of 19 to make all of a sudden the
transition
it is but I've had a small run up to it
all the last six months
and next bit of Charles and I can't go
wrong he's there with me I'm amazed that
she's been brave enough to take me on
and I suppose in love
[Music]
foreign
the Gilded surroundings of the
goldsmiths hall in the city of London
were chosen quite deliberately by the
palace in order to show Lady Diana off
to the best Advantage for her first
public appearance
do you remember what your first ever
memory was in this life yes yeah I
remember my first engagement so well
I remember being so excited I got this
black dress from the emmanuels
it was in Black tatheter it was off the
shoulder and by normal Royal standards
it was fairly revealing
I thought it was okay because girls of
my age wore this
I hadn't appreciated that I was now seen
as a royal lady
although I'd only got a ring on my
finger as opposed to two rings
and I remember walking into my husband
to be study and saying I'm ready you
needed you're not going in that dress
are you
and I said yes I am
he said it's black
I said yes it's black only people in
morning wear black messages but I'm not
part of your family yet
black to me was the smartest colleague
of course we have at the age of 19 was a
real grown-up dress
she looked pretty relaxed considering
this must have been something of an
ordeal for her
and I was quite big gestured then and
everyone got frankly excited
I learned Less on that night I remember
meeting Princess Grace
and one of the performers was Princess
Grace of Monaco
she of course is very experienced at
this sort of occasion and the often
tricky business of making small talk
she also knows how to give a helping
hand to a newcomer
and how to pose for the cameras which
Lady Diana is now learning
I didn't know whether to get out the
door first
no their handbags should be carrying
your left hand not your right hand
everything was all over the place
I remember that evening so well
I was terrified
he was sick
when I arrived at Clarence house there
was a letter on my birds from Camilla
dated two days previous saying such
exciting news about the engagement
do let's have lunch soon when Rick Ross
goes to Australia New Zealand
and love to see the ring lots of love
Camilla
and that was
wow
you may recall seeing a picture of me
sobbing in a red coat and he went off
when did everything
that was nothing to do with him Gary
the most awful thing had happened before
we went
how's the new study talking to him about
this trip telephone
just before he's going five weeks
so I thought should I be nice or should
I just sit here
so I thought it'd be nice I left them to
it
and just break my heart there
so I organized badge
we had lunch and very tricky very tricky
indeed she said you're not going to
untie you I said no
just wanted to know that
but as far as she was concerned that was
her communication
I was still too immature to understand
all the messages coming my way
and then someone in his office told me
that my husband had a bracelet made for
her
I walked into this man's office one day
and I said oh what's in that parcel oh
he said you shouldn't look at that I
said well I'm going to look at it so I
opened it and there was a bracelet
[Music]
I was devastated and he said well he's
going to give it to her tonight
so rage rage rage you know why can't you
be honest with me
but no obviously cut me dead it's as if
he'd made a decision if it wasn't going
to work it wasn't going to work
he found the Virgin sacrificial lamb and
in a way he was obsessed with me but
it's hot and cold hot cold you never
knew what mood it was going to be up
down up and down
I went upstairs I had lunch with my
sisters who were there and I said I
can't no I can't do this this is
absolutely unbelievable and they were
wonderful and said well bad luck that's
your face on the tea towel so you're too
late to chicken out
news of Lady Diana's visit spread
quickly Shoppers waited in pouring rain
while staff from nearby officers
abandoned work for half an hour
Lady Sarah Spencer was there to give her
sister's opinion of the wedding dress
it's been slightly altered
the crowd saw that like most Brides Lady
Diana has lost weight as the day
approaches
I believe you started the week after you
got engaged
my husband put his hand on my waistline
and said oh a bit chubby here aren't we
and that triggered off something in me
and remember the first time I made
myself say I'm so thrilled
because I thought right this is the
release tension
first time I got measured for my wedding
dress I was 29 around the waist
the day I got married I was 23 and a
half
shrunk into nothing
the public side was the age of novice
from the perhaps had
public side they wanted a fairy princess
and then everything would turn into gold
and all their worries would be forgotten
actually did they realize that the
individual was crucifying herself inside
me why I always publicity
we got married on Wednesday and on
Monday we'd gone to support for our last
rehearsal
and that's when all the camera lights
were on full
and I saw my eyes out absolutely
collapsed
and it was collapsing because of all
sorts of things
will come in I think rearing its head
the whole way through our engagement
and I was desperately trying to be
mature about the situation but I didn't
have the foundation to do it I couldn't
talk to anyone about it
little Diana meeting so many people is
still quite new to how have you reacted
to this warmth and affection it's been a
tremendous boost
and just a mass of smiling faces
it's wonderful quite emotional too oh
very very nice one thing that I know
some pools have done to make it from
their point of view very personal they
were telling me that where you're going
to make your vows they've made a
platform so that at least you can feel
that you're together and alone because I
think everyone would agree when you make
your vows that's the most solemn the
most precious and a very personal moment
is it going to be that for you even
though you know the eyes of the world
are watching you at that very important
moment
I hope so yes
but I'm more used to it I think probably
now knowing for years
the cameras
poking at you from every quarter and
recording every twitch you make so you
can get used to a certain extent and on
those occasions you accept that that's
part of it I think if you don't try to
work out in your own mind some kind of
method for existing
and surviving this kind of thing you you
would get mad I think I don't know did
you find that our last six months you're
beginning to get used Jazz
it is I suppose one of the most
important things you're going to have to
adjust to really isn't it
and Prince Charles has been a great help
to you and that's right the Tower of
strength
gracious I have to say that because
you're sitting there
I'm sure you would anyway
I remember my husband sent me a very
nice Signet room the night before to
Clarence House with the Prince of Wales
feathers on it and a very nice car that
said
I'm so proud of you I'll be there at the
altar for you tomorrow just look them in
the eye and look I'm dead
I had a very bad fit of bulimia the
night before I ate everything I could
possibly find which amuse my sister
because she was staying at Clarence
House with me
nobody understood what was going on
there it was sort of hush-hush
as sick as a parent that night and it
was such an indication of what was going
on
next morning when we're getting up craft
house I must have been awake about five
and I was very very deathly calm deathly
deathly calm
I felt has allowed the slaughter
and I knew it
[Laughter]
at the household Cavalry Barracks horses
were awakened and mucking out began in
preparation for a day for which both men
and horses have been practicing for
weeks
along the Route both crowds and
excitement were building by eight
o'clock police estimated 900 000 people
were already out in central London
[Applause]
before he left home Lord Spencer the
proudest of men today wanted a few words
I just like to say a word may I say a
word
the suspensers have through the
centuries fought for their King and
Country
today Diana is vying to help her country
for the rest of her life
she will be following in the tradition
of her ancestors
and she will have at aside the man she
loves
and then just after half past 10 from
Clarence House became the glass catch
and our first chance to see Lady Diana
dress Hopkins Veil tantalizing noulo
the coach no you're so thrilled
waved himself stupid
we went past Martin's in the field and
then you thought we were at St Paul so
he's ready to get out
it was wonderful that
I don't think I was happy I think I was
I never tried to call it off in the
sense of really doing that but
I think the worst day of my life
[Music]
oh
I cried a lot on the Monday when we done
the rehearsal because detention suddenly
hit me but by Wednesday I was fine
and I had to get my father basically up
the yarn that's what I concentrated on
[Music]
and I remember being totally worried
Curts into the queen
walking down the aisle I spotted Camilla
pale gray veiled hat pill box hat sorry
door
her son Tom standing on a chair to this
day you know vivid memory
and I thought well there we are that's
that's it let's hope that's all over
with
Charles Philip Arthur George
will thou have this woman to thy wedded
wife
to live together after God's ordinance
in the holiest state of matrimony
will thou love her comfort her honor and
keep her in sickness and in health
and forsaking all other teeth they only
unto her
so long as you both shall live I will
I Diana Francis hi Joanna Francis take
the Charles Philip Arthur George
to my wedding husband to my wedded
husband to Heaven to Hell
from this day forward this day forward
for better for worse for better for us
for richer for Potter richer in sickness
and in health in sickness and in health
to love and to cherish love and to
cherish till death us too hard
yeah is the stuff of which fairy tales
are made
the prince and princess on their wedding
day
and I remember being so in love with my
husband that I couldn't take my eyes off
and I just absolutely well as the
luckiest girl in the world and you know
he was going to look after me
[Applause]
[Music]
the wonderful feeling of everybody
hooray everybody happy and everybody
happy because they thought we were happy
and there was a big question mark in my
mind
and into the afternoon sunshine day came
Prince Charles and the new Princess of
Wales smiling and looking wonderfully
relaxed
I just had tremendous hope in me
which was Slash
by day two
my husband took eight Lawrence fans
possible novels Along on our honeymoon
well now to read
so every lunchtime or dinner time when
we were allowed to be on our own we were
supposed to read them through never on
our own
I remember crying my heart out on my
honeymoon I was so tired
for all the wrong reasons totally
you can now say that the honeymoon has
really started actually it gets more
like a romantic novel as the minutes go
on all the old cliches come to mind like
and so we say farewell and at last We're
Alone darling
[Music]
we're opening our diary to discuss
various things
out comes two pictures of Camilla
and on our honeymoon Catholics arrive on
his wrists two seas in twine like the
Chanel sea
got it in one knew exactly so I said
Camilla gave you those didn't she you
said yes so what's wrong they're present
from a friend
and boy do we have a row
jealousy potato
and it was such a good idea the two C's
but it wasn't that clever
by then the bulimia were appalling
absolutely appalling it was Rife it's
four times a day on the yacht
anything I could find I would gobble up
and be sick two minutes later
we survived that all right
okay we went off to balmore Straight
From New York
foreign
set in
my dreams were appalling at night I
dreamed criminal the whole time
everybody thought I'm getting thin and
thinner and thinner
I was being sicker and sick and sicker
[Applause]
basically if they thought I could adapt
being princess a whale overnight
we stayed up there from August to
October
by October I was about to
cut my wrists
I was in a very bad way a random range
of rain and I came down early from
balmor to seek treatments not because I
hate about more but because I was in
such a bad way
couldn't sleep
didn't eat
a whole world was collapsing around me
all the analysts psychiatrists never
dreamed of came plodding in tried to
sort me out
put me on high doses of Valium
it was me telling them what I needed
they were telling me pills were going to
keep them happy they could go to bed at
night and sleep knowing the Princess of
Wales was going to stab anyone
but the Diana that was still very much
there decided that it was just time
patience and adapting all that was
needed
anyway a godsend William was conceived
in October marvelous news occupied my
mind
Lady Diana Spencer became the Princess
of Wales in a ceremony watched by the
world at the end of July Buckingham
Palace today said she's expecting the
baby will be second in line to the
British throne
whether or not the baby is to be born
here has yet to be decided that's
largely a question for the Queen's
gynecologist George Pinker who will be
attending the princess throughout very
very difficult pregnancy indeed sick the
whole time bulimia and morning sickness
and this family's never had anybody
who's had morning sickness before
so every time in my evening dress I had
to go out of the fainted or I was sick
so I was a problem and I registered Dan
was a problem she's different she's
doing everything that we never did why
it was Charles's Choice when we first
got married not to run around
he wanted to try and have a home life of
some sort
but he didn't know how to do it he's
never been taught so the whole thing
just evaporated
I threw myself down the stairs
Charles Stars crying wolf and I said I
just felt so desperate and I was crying
my eyes out
and he said I'm not going to listen
you're always doing this to me he said
I'm going riding now
so I threw myself down the stairs
bearing in mind I was carrying a child
quite bruised around the stomach Queen
comes out
absolutely horrified or shaking she's so
frightened
and Charles went out riding and when he
came back you know he was just dismissal
where we had William we was trying to
date the door that suited him he's Polo
William had to be induced because I
couldn't handle the Press pressure any
longer it's becoming unbearable
because as if everybody was monitoring
every day for me
and I was aware that the whole country
was holding its breath
went in very early
and are sick as a parent the whole way
through the labor
Supreme anybody
very bad labor they want caesarean
um no one told me to still afterwards
[Applause]
[Music]
great excitement
everyone's absolutely hard as a kite
[Applause]
I knew it was a boy
I was just thrilled
[Applause]
and no he's lucky enough doctor how do
you feel so difficult to tell at the
moment how do you feel I'm obviously
relieved and delighted it's marvelous
it's rather grown-up thing I found my
brother was shocked to my
sister's form that's the baby
yes
is that a blondish
it probably goes something else later on
I've been singing uh well done Charlie
let's have another one
but he'll give us a chance
who asked my wife I know they should be
too please just yet have you thought of
a name yet sir have you thought of a
name yet there is order 102.
bit of an argument about yourself
William Arthur Philip Louis how about
that that's so clearing yes you said
Louie yeah are you happy with William
yes
King William Prince William you think
Regal ring King William
yes King bill
[Applause]
may we see your son your own highness
how good a dad was he with the children
at the beginning we loved the nursery
life and you just couldn't wait to get
back
and do the bottle
[Music]
came home and then personal Depression
hit me hard
and it wasn't so much a baby that was
produced
it was a baby that triggered off all
else that was going on in my mind if
Charles didn't come home when he said
was coming home
tears Panic all the rest of it
he didn't see the panic I would just sit
there can't leave
boy was out of trouble
[Music]
Williams Christie was desperate because
I literally had just given birth
there's only six weeks old
and it was all decided around me
hence the ghostly pictures of somebody
who was so am I believe that everything
was out of control yeah everything
I was treated like nobody else's
business on the 4th of August
[Music]
anybody asked me when that was suitable
for William
11 o'clock couldn't have been worse
[Music]
ends pictures of the queen Queen Mother
Charles and William
[Music]
okay I was excluded totally in that day
okay stop well with the amount of story
is that there are in our newspapers and
on television you could hardly fail to
notice of The Prince and the Princess of
Wales and of course Young Prince William
are now well into the swing of their
tour of Australia
Brisbane was the place where they
expected the biggest crowds of the tour
and they got them
the police estimated there were 80 000
people here but Wise Old locals reckon
there were nearer a hundred thousand
ladies and gentlemen the last time I was
here was two years ago in 1981 shortly
before we were married
and at that time everybody was saying
good luck and I hope everything goes
well and how lucky you are to be engaged
to such a lovely lady and my goodness I
was lucky enough to marry her and we had
many many messages
amazing what ladies do in your back step
thank you
everybody always said when we were in
the car oh we're on the wrong side we
want to see home don't want to see him
and that's all we could hear as we went
down these crowds
and obviously he wasn't used to that nor
was I he took it out on me he was
jealous
I understood the jealousy but I couldn't
explain that I didn't ask for it
and I've come to the conclusion that
really it would have been far easier to
have had two wives
to have covered both sides of the street
and I could have walked down the middle
directing the operation
[Music]
between William and Harry being born
it's total darkness
I can't remember much I've lost it out
in such pain
people for you to talk to yes did you
have any choice
Dr Mitchell came in every evening at six
o'clock on how to explain to him about
my conversation with my husband during
the day and they weren't many
conversations with small tears and
anything else
because on the outside people were
saying I was giving my husband a hard
time I was actually like a sports child
but I knew that I was just needed rest
and patience and time to adapt to all
the roles that were acquired on me
overnight
by then there's immense jealousy because
every single day I was on the front of
the newspaper
anyway I repaired by miracle
Charles and I we were very very close to
each other the six weeks we're home for
places we've ever ever been and ever
will have been
[Music]
and then somebody's Harry was born it
just went Bang
our marriage whole thing went down the
drain
good evening the princess of wales's new
baby born at 20 past four this afternoon
is another boy both are doing well the
new Prince not yet named weighed 6
pounds 14 ounces he has pale blue eyes
and according to his father
indeterminate color hair
I knew Harry was going to be a boy
because I saw in the scan and Charles
all he wanted was a girl
who wants two children and he wanted to
go
I knew her as a boy and I didn't tell
him
[Applause]
his name is Henry Charles Albert David
but they're going to call him Harry
who chose the name I did I chose William
and Harry but Charles for the rest
because he wanted Albert and Arthur and
I said no too old
no thank you
Harry ride Harry was a boy first comment
was oh God it's a boy
is something inside me closed off and by
then I knew he'd gone back to his lady
but somehow we managed to have Harry
and how is complete joy and he's
actually closer to his father and
perhaps brilliant
[Music]
yes Four Hands Two Princes and the piano
he fell
well now two questions that everybody
will want to have answered what do you
say when you read in the papers that you
are a determined domineering woman
I I don't always read that I'm I'm
people
very willing to tell me that but I I
don't think I am I'm a perfectionist
with myself but not necessarily with
everybody else
and that those stories arose long time
ago and have kept coming out again and
again but I don't think I'm
you feel hurt by them well obviously one
does you feel very wounded and
if it comes out you think oh gosh I
don't want to go out do my engagement
this morning nobody wants to see me help
panic but you've got to push yourself
out and remember uh that some people
hopefully won't believe everything they
read about you because there's far too
much about me in the newspapers far too
much horrifies me when there's something
more important like what goes on in the
hospice or there's been a bomb or
something so put me on the front page I
feel underdressed
the flesh
well don't let junior might get a shot
I've seen enough photos I know there's
too many of those salted in the shop
downstairs how much do you sell them for
three pounds 10 that one's okay is that
all
but there is a natural and continuing
interest in you for example have you
actually tried to change Prince Charles
in any way since you got married not at
all I mean obviously the one or two
things like maybe the
they are Thai or something but nothing
shoes we won't get any further but that
that but but
nothing dramatic
well you both like skiing and yet every
year it has become irregular you don't
appear to hit it off exactly eye to eye
on the slopes
what is the secret of this
YouTube
I think I can help it
I suspect most husbands and wives found
that they often have arguments but we
don't no no but occasionally we do
because I mean I
go on longer sometimes yes but I'm
faster
of course some people say that you're so
slim you probably don't eat enough
anyway
when we go on an engagement if it's a
lunchtime one we often have a buffy
lunch so we can get around the normal
Spanish people there sometimes are so
it's impossible to talk and eat at the
same time so you end up chasing a bit of
chicken around the plate and they're
never getting anything yourself and by
the time you get home certainly there's
no time you're rushing off somewhere
else but I'm never on what's called a
diet
maybe I'm so scrawny it's because I take
so much exercise
I don't know
in what way would the queen evolved
she indicated to me that she thought
that was a reason why our marriage had
gone downhill
it's because Charles was having such a
difficult time with Donna's bulimia
yes
she hung the coat on the hook so to
speak
and it made me realize that they all saw
that as the cause of their marriage not
one of the symptoms of the marriage
any wise heads during the whole thing
that will help
all right they saw that something was
going wrong but nobody actually I never
lent on anyone none of my family knew
about this at all
after five years of being married my
sister Jane came out to see me and I had
a v-neck on
she said that's what's that marking on
your chest and I said it's nothing so
what is it
and the night before I wanted to talk to
Charles about something he wouldn't
listen to me starts crying well so I
picked up his pen knife off his dressing
table and um scratched myself
Heaven down my chest and my both eyes it
was a lot of blood
and it hadn't made any reaction
whatsoever to him and she went for me
she said I must let the side down and I
turned on her and I said give me some
credit
that I haven't traveled any of you in my
family for five years practice
and obviously their perception is very
different now they're annoyed by the
lack of support from him
it's a particular pleasure to be able to
introduce my wife to this Great Pacific
province
and let us see
and to let us see for herself and to
find out for herself just what a warm
Hearts he locked you all up
then things got a bit tricky yes and the
Expo the Expo where I passed out yeah
I remember I never paid before in my
life and we'd be walking around for four
hours without any food I presume I
hadn't eaten for days beforehandling
when I say that I mean food's staying
down
and I remember walking around feeling
really gassed and I didn't dare tell him
what I felt gas because I thought they
think I was whinge
I put my arm on my husband's shell
addresses I've done anything I'm about
to disappear
down the side of him
my husband told me off he said I
couldn't pass that quietly somewhere
else
and everyone was saying she can't go out
to that she can't go out and actually
she must have had some sleep
so I said she must go out tonight
otherwise there's going to be a sense
for terrific drama they're gonna think
there's something really awful wrong
with it
inside me I knew there was something
wrong with me but it was too in the
children's voice yet
this afternoon the prince and princess
said farewell to BC they're going to
Tokyo to begin a royal tour that
includes at least five 12-hour days and
Royal officials say there are no plans
to change the schedule
and
no they were running around they
couldn't understand it was like sort of
Marilyn Monroe publicity you know
she only had to trick a hill and the
whole world was just a feed it was very
hard
but I'm never comfortable in it never
ever
[Music]
couldn't believe it
[Applause]
they all thoughts there's still lots of
customers for doing all right
but that summer is that why something
has got one
I remember saying to myself right down
it's not good
I'm gonna change it right now
remember my conversation so well sitting
by water I will sit by water
to grow up you've got to be responsible
you've got to understand but you can't
do what other 26 27 year olds are doing
you've been chosen to do a position so
you must adapt to it and stop fighting
it
and I knew we could do it
but I chose a different Channel
the Princess of Wales felt not the
slightest apprehension about her visit
to the Middlesex Hospital and its AIDS
Ward
all the speculation had centered on
whether she would wear gloves when
shaking hands with the staff and
patients
welcome to the hug people in hospital
bed in his prediction arms so ill so I
think where Diana do it come on just do
it so I gave my mom's hug and it was
just so touchy counting and cried and he
was wonderful we made me laugh
in Britain The public's obsession with
the royal family has reached New Heights
or lows depending on how you look at it
the cause of the latest flurry of
excitement is the rumor that Prince
Charles and Princess Diana may be on the
verge of ending their marriage
but whatever problems they may be having
says Andrew Morton Royal reporter for
the British newspaper the star there's
no chance the two will get divorced
they're as much likely to get divorced
as I am to get pregnant
I mistake my life on the fact that they
will never ever ever divorce
24 hours before the royal visit parts of
carmarthen were still under several feet
of water
today the floods had subsided as the
lengthy job of clearing up was underway
one of the worst things that ever
happens when we went to Wales after
flooding and there'd been a tremendous
amount of press for us being apart
and I burst into tears when he got in
the plane he said oh God what's the
matter I said I've had a very bad time
with the Press because they had
literally halted me and hunted me
and he said well if you were in the
right place none of this would happen
indicating that Ashby I was gone
it was a real Cry for Help I wasn't just
blubbing because I just turned the Taps
on it was just desperation
it's only the couple's second public
appearance together in over a month but
tomorrow they'll go their separate ways
again the princess stays in London
Prince Charles goes to Scotland
I said I choose to work that's my role
in life
[Music]
what do you think
actually
I suddenly realized what I was going to
lose if I let go
and was it worth it
so that's how I got involved with the
foreign
so I had myself say four times
I asked all these questions and I was
able to be completely honest
things that are going to come and see
once a week for an hour I'm just going
to talk it through
he said there's nothing wrong with you
and when you said that a door opens
I thought well maybe it's not me
and he helped me get back my self-esteem
for the first formal dinner of the visit
the princess unveiled another new look
her hair worn up with a tiara that
clearly won the approval of State
president Von viseker the cameras were
concentrating on the princess interest
in her clothes replacing speculation
about the Royal marriage
and she seemed relaxed enough to respond
in informal manner when one photographer
complimented her hairstyle
one of the bravest moments of my entire
team was was
a 40th birthday party from nurses and
noticed that she'd turn up but again the
voice of Simon said just go for hello
foreign
[Music]
I didn't bite but I was very very
honored
I walk into the house and
I think she got over that
[Music]
we were all upstairs and I was chatting
around I suddenly there was no child's
upstairs
so this disturbs me so I make my way to
go downstairs again I know what I'm
going to confront myself
try and stop me from going downstairs no
they don't go down there
I'm just gonna find one husband
I go downstairs it's a very happy little
threesome going on downstairs with my
left child
this is your moment
so I went and joining the conversation
so we're best friends
and I said uh come on I'd love to have a
word
and she got really uncomfortable for the
headache oh yes that's too many okay
boys
and uh I'll be up in a minute
and this shot upstairs like chickens
with their heads and I could feel
upstairs all hell breaking with what is
she going to do
so I said come on let's sit down and
switch that time I was terrified of her
and I said come and I just like to
change I know it's actually what's going
on
I don't know
and I said I know what's going on
and she said to me very interesting she
said to me we've got everything you've
ever wanted
all men in the world
we've got two beautiful children and I
haven't really watched it anyway so I
said I want my husband
and she said well shut down the whole
time
I said I'm sorry I'm in the way I don't
see Adam in the way and it must be
Health birthday but I didn't know what's
going on
rash
I cried like I've never cried before it
was anger it was seven years of Pentagon
coming out cried cried
I didn't see that night
and the next one we woke up and I felt
different shift tremendous I'd done
something except what I felt
story of jealous in here I go swimming
around but it wasn't so deaf because
it's been before
nicer tune for the weekend three days I
accidentally Giants
coming up
there's no secret you may ask her
I just said I loved you
there's nothing wrong in there
six seven eight nine ten one two three
four five
oh nice it's been quite interesting bits
and pieces in there
now once you've got down here
questions here we are
what have been returning moments in life
yeah what triggered enough I suppose
last summer when Sam cut my hair
differently let out something quite
different
and when my bulimic finished two years
ago my son felt so much stronger
mentally and physically so I was able to
Soldier on
[Music]
I've got what my mother's got what
however bloody you're feeling you can
put on the most amazing show of
happiness
[Music]
but what I couldn't COPE in those Dark
Ages was people saying it's it's her
fault and I got that everywhere
everywhere
and then the system and museums starting
to stay out of my God
and I was the Marilyn Monroe of the
1980s and that I was doing
I've never ever sat down and said hooray
how wonderful
never it's the day I do that we're in
trouble
I am a former Duty as the Princess of
Wales and my time as allocated and if I
go anywhere else I go somewhere else if
life changes it changes but at least
when I finished my as I see it my 12 or
15 years as much as well so I don't see
it any longer fine enough
I know when I turn my light up and I did
my best
and you always knew I'd wanna be in next
week put it that way
and no one said that to me I just knew
it
foreign
ers
[Music]
in what way
s of Prince than I would have opted for
a visit to the Taj Mahal and the Red
Fort at Agra
which I believe is where some at least
of the greatest pundits of the press
think I ought to be anyway rather than
making a greater fool of myself here
as the Princess of Wales delivered
Prince Harry to his school this morning
the author of the book which claims to
expose the real state of her marriage
said he left very strong material out of
his account because it would have
revealed the identity of several key
sources the book due to go on sale
tomorrow claims she made several
attempts on her life not serious
attempts but what it says were desperate
cries for help
the author Andrew Morton insisted today
that close friends of the princess stand
by the Integrity of the book and he came
on itn's lunchtime news to make his
first live defense of the book on
television
the motivation was to tell the truth for
once forget the propaganda tell the
truth about what's really going on
because we do face a crisis in the house
of winter it's obvious to everyone and
make you and make you a rich man well if
that's a corollary then so be it but
hopefully people it struck a nerve
because it is true it is a true story
it's a sympathetic account of her life
we are not in the business of hyping
Publications was the only comment from
Buckingham Palace this morning Palace
officials refused to comment on whether
they had a copy of the book or where the
top libel lawyers were examining the
text
the secrecy surrounding one of the most
publicized books ever is remarkable the
bookshops have been straining at the bit
for a glimpse of what is arguably the
most talked about book of all time
the hype behind this book is virtually
unprecedented but according to Andrew
Morton the story stands up he says Diana
is a victim who became a princess before
she became a woman and as a result she
hit what she herself called the Dark
Ages
the book serialized in the Sunday Times
today claims it was the prince's
indifference to his wife that caused her
chronic depression and five separate
suicide attempts at the Queen's cup Polo
tournament in Windsor Great Park this
afternoon all attention was on Camilla
Parker Bowles a longtime friend of
Prince Charles a relationship which the
book claims sparked off jealousy in the
princess Buckingham Palace officials
have denied once again today that the
Princess of Wales cooperated in any way
with the book and refuses to dignify its
claims with any further comments but the
repercussions are continuing
and what about the role of of Prince
Charles in in this rather sad if you say
Cry for Help I think the Prince Charles
has a tremendous responsibility towards
the princess Wales and I think the
Prince Charles is very sad
that the princess should have seen said
to air the problems in the marriage so
publicly
I am trying to bring some balance to
this whole story I I think that we've
had nothing but Diana's misery and
Diana's loneliness and Diana's side of
the story we've heard her say how
Charles is a bad father how he's a bad
husband he's uncaring he drove her to
suicide attempt and I think the time has
simply come to to adjust the balance
Prince Charles is not a cold man he is
not an uncaring man the fact of the
matter is that because of Diana's
illness
everything has built up in her mind she
has created
situations she
imagined situations
Charles and Diana's storybook wedding
has collapsed into a royal embarrassment
Separate Lives public scrutiny Whispers
of infidelity
and there were signs today that it's all
getting to be too much for the princess
Royal composure collapsed as Princess
Diana under extraordinary media
attention broke down in tears red-faced
and Confused this was a side of the
prince's never seen in public and all
that you do
[Music]
philosophy of tender loving care
which is and always will be the Hallmark
of this hospice Diana appeared near
tears in her first public engagement
since a book detailing her unhappiness
was published last week
[Applause]
it began as a royal romance but quickly
faded Britain's Prince Charles and Lady
Diana in the latter years a troubled
marriage and mostly Separate Lives she
reportedly described it as a Loveless
misalliance well today official word the
union is over
the couple will continue to carry out
separate engagements and duties the
Princess of Wales has already done much
to establish herself as a solo operator
whether or not the Princess of Wales
will become Queen May finally be decided
by Queen Elizabeth herself and when she
chooses to abdicate
a lot of people question whether she's
entitled to wear the crown and it's very
important for us that the dignity and
the statue of the monarchy is protected
and I think that might well reduce it
rather than enhance it
if I was able to write my own script I
would say that I would hope my husband
would go off with his lady
and sort that out and leave me and the
children to carry the Wales name through
to the time when William
sent the throne
[Music]
might be behind them all away
and I can do this job so much better on
my own
[Music]
little trapped
good
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
a Royal Highness the Princess of Wales
would like to make a short statement
your Royal Highness
thank you
when I started my public life 12 years
ago
I understood the media might be
interested in what I did
I realized then their attention would
inevitably focus on both our private and
public lives
[Music]
but I was not aware of how overwhelming
that attention would become
at the end of this year
when I've completed my diary of official
engagements
I will be reducing the extent of the
public life I've LED so far
my first priority will continue to be
our children William and Harry who
deserve as much love and care and
attention as I am able to give
I couldn't stand here today and make
this sort of statement without
acknowledging the heartfelt support I've
been given by the public in general
your kindness and affection has carried
me through some of the most difficult
periods
and always your love and care has eased
that Journey
and for that I thank you from the bottom
of my heart
[Applause]
amid the chaos of Luanda airport a
scheduled flight at the start of an
unofficial visit for the newest and most
high-profile Red Cross volunteer
for the first time on her own stepping
out into the third world reunited with
the charity she deserted before her
divorce from Prince Charles
it's an enormous privilege for me to be
invited here to Angola in order to
assist the Red Cross in its campaign to
ban once and for all anti-personal
landmines
has the reality of Angola been more
shocking than you expected yes I knew
the statistics but putting a face to
those figures brought the reality home
to me
like when I met Sandra the 13 year old
girl two days ago who had lost her leg
for people like her you know the rest of
her life will be very different
we must stop the landmines if we can
I would have thought that was the most
important question out of the two I go
for that one
no no
I mean the one saying I'm not a
political figure
surprised at the political Fury that
came out as a result of your visit here
to Angola
it was merely a distraction and the fact
is I'm a humanitarian figure not one who
is a political political story can we do
that again
foreign
I saw it merely as a distraction because
I'm not a political figure I I am a
humanitarian figure
and always have been and always will be
it is not the horror of land mines that
is making the headlines back home but
reports of the princess's romance with
Dodie fiad
I see myself one day living abroad and
you once said to me last week she said
to me you're gonna know someone who's
far then
I thought it was always interesting
there
confirmation of Princess Diana's first
serious romance since her split with
Charles will be shown in London Sunday
Mirror tomorrow Paparazzi photographer
Maria Brenner is set to become a
millionaire from worldwide sales of the
shots
she wants this romance on the record and
this is a story that's going to run and
run until something wonderful or
something ghastly happens
I have been positive about it for some
time
I'm obviously that's endless question
marks
you're quite nice skin do things like a
weekend in Paris
I know one day I play the game of life I
will be able to have those things which
I've always pined for and they'll be
that much more special because I'll be
that much more older and be able to
appreciate them that much more
thank you
we interrupt this film to tell you we
are getting reports that Diana Princess
of Wales has been badly injured in a car
crash in France
Stephen Jessel our correspondent in
Paris what is your view of what is now
happening at the hospital
[Music]
one wonders if one is being told the
whole truth at the moment
once heart goes out especially to the
young princess William and Harry indeed
William let's remind ourselves he
particularly close to his mother a very
sensitive young man hates photographers
this is the irn news desk this message
is I repeat is not for public broadcast
Diana Princess of Wales has died
I know that these pictures are being
beamed around the world and maybe people
in some parts of the world will think
this is quite a normal scene
little do they know
in America I know for a fact people have
got up early
to watch live Transmissions from London
in the Far East where it's well well
into the day now late afternoon early
evening they're sitting watching
television schedules have been cleared
around the world
this is an extraordinary view we're
seeing here we've never as far as I'm
aware seen the royal family standing
like this at the gates of Buckingham
Palace
could they be intending to walk behind
the coffin
anything is possible today
the word Diana on a huge Banner on the
gate and no one said that mustn't be
there you don't put posters or banners
on the gates of Buckingham Palace Diana
of love
Prince William Earl Spencer
Prince Harry
and the prince of Wales almost
intolerable moment
the two boys the Two Princes
impossible
to put into words
as they take their place
behind their mother's coffin
of all the irony is about Diana perhaps
the greatest was this
a girl given the name of the ancient
goddess of hunting was in the end the
most hunted person of the Modern Age she
would want us today to pledge ourselves
to protecting her beloved boys William
and Harry from a similar fate
and I do this here Diana on your behalf
Diana was the very essence of compassion
of Duty of style of beauty
all over the world she was a symbol of
selfless Humanity
a standard Bearer for the rights of the
truly downtrodden
someone with a natural nobility who was
classless and who proved in the last
year that she needed no royal title to
continue to generate her particular
brand of magic
there is no doubt that she was looking
for a new Direction in her life at this
time
she talked endlessly of getting away
from England mainly because of the
treatment that she received at the hands
of the newspapers
I don't think she ever understood why
her genuinely good intentions were
snared at by the media why there
appeared to be a permanent Quest on
their behalf to bring her down
above all we give thanks for the life of
a woman I'm so proud to be able to call
my sister
the unique the complex the extraordinary
and irreplaceable Diana
whose Beauty both internal and external
will never be extinguished from our
minds
[Music]
foreign
she affected everybody and that's
everyone's way of showing it
laying their flowers and writing their
cards and their poems it's just amazing
but she'll never know how much she meant
to everybody really
[Music]
she was just so human she made so many
mistakes and just exactly like we do and
yet she Shone through it
the public side was very different
obviously perhaps had
public side they wanted a pairing
princess
touched them and everything returned to
gold
and all their worries would be forgotten
[Music]
so did they realize that the individual
was crucifying herself inside
she was going off and why me why I
always published it
and when I first arrived on the cinema I
put my head down
now from that point do I interpreted yes
it did look silky
just so frightened of the attention I
was getting
head down
which I can't remember is that he wants
to do anything on my own
you're fine
tremors
so I stuck with whatever Charles did and
it included a wife I went with him all
the way wherever
I was just so desperate I knew what was
wrong with me
but nobody else around me understood me
I needed rest and to be looked after
inside my house I have people to
understand the torment and the anguish
going on in my head
because I had a smile on my face nobody
didn't touch me one time
probably chose to think that they're
happy of thinking that
didn't get easier I just got used to
what people would have cried from
Princess of Wales what Diana thought
wasn't going to come into it yet
history fascinated me but I never
anticipated I'd end up in the system
history in the books
as it is
I am altering it for him but in a subtle
way
people aren't aware of it I am through
William learning what I do
and his father to a certain extent he
has got an Insider what's coming his way
he's not hidden upstairs for governors
to not Bear Down depression you know not
let all this chat disturb me took me 16
and set comfortable in the skin
and now I'm ready to go bored
I hug my children to death
I get in bed with them at night and hug
them and I always say who loves you most
in the whole wide world and they always
say mommy you know all right and it's
always that I always feed them
so important
[Music]
did you have any expectations looking
forwards
I have so many dreams as a young girl
hopes that my husband look after me
would be like a father figure
you'd support me encourage me say Well
done obviously no it wasn't good enough
I knew somehow I had to keep myself very
tidy for whatever will come in my way
I was always different I had always a
singing inside of me that I was going
somewhere different I didn't know why
I couldn't even talk about it
was grandchild
wasn't anything dramatic
I'm blinking a little coldness
[Music]